guess what the minimalists are going on
tour with a live version of the
minimalists podcast
and i want to invite you to join us for
a night of less find your nearest city
at the minimalists comm slash tour we'll
see you there so so Jeanette you I think
this is true you you have people who are
really rooting for you they want you to
succeed they want to watch whatever
you're doing next but there are also
other people who who seems like no
matter what you do you can never do
right and in their eyes why do we think
that is it's it's an interesting area
because I think like I can speak I guess
specifically to the kind of like child
stardom teenage stardom thing
because I feel like that's what people
are even more interest like people are
even more interested in seeing a former
child star fail right like there's like
Lindsay Lohan Britney Spears I mean
Macaulay Culkin Justin Beiber even there
it's like there's the the idea of
pulling down their narrative and making
them into this crazy like person having
a mental breakdown I don't I don't
understand the fascination with it I
wish that wasn't the case I think it
perpetuates whoever's experiencing
probably some real mental health
struggles it makes it worse for them I
wish that society didn't do that to
people it bothers me so much god it
bothers me so much I don't know what
needs to change or how it can change I
was actually watching a documentary on
Lindsay Lohan the other day and a
paparazzi dude was interview he was like
somebody was following him and he's like
I don't get why she doesn't like me I
don't get why she doesn't want to smile
for the camera like shouldn't she love
this I'm getting her attention shouldn't
she love this no you're chasing her down
like you're following her why would she
love it it doesn't make any sense to me
you know what I think it makes sense to
him because that's what he wants he
wants someone to he wants that level of
attention or at least let me rephrase
that that's what he thinks he wants
until he gets it now Ryan and I have
this weird sort of level of we're not
famous but we are well-known enough that
occasionally people recognize us Oh
but I get recognized all the time when
I'm with Josh curious how much people
like it like is it normal for people to
shout out their windows how often does
this happen yeah I mean five six times a
day maybe but it's not it's not enough
where it's like if I'm walking through a
crowd it's one out of 50 people maybe
and so like it's not but you never know
who that one out of 50 people are right
yeah and if it's one out of 50 people
who say something then it's what another
four or five who don't say something but
still it's the vast vast majority have
no idea who we are and I'm completely
contented with that but there is a there
is a level and it's sort of like it's
sort of like grains of sand like how
many grains of sand make a beach right
like at some point there's a level where
it is a beach but you know one grain of
sand is not a beach like what is the
level of notoriety that makes a person
famous I don't know but from a very
young age you had to deal with with
being recognized and and and how were
you how did you deal with that early on
it was not easy I think some people are
naturally just kind of good at Fame like
maybe their personality type or family
history I'm not sure what makes a person
good at fame but I was I felt incredibly
anxious like there is there was a time
now it's totally it's completely
manageable it's not difficult at all it
doesn't feel like a hindrance on my life
but there is a time from probably 14
years old to 22 where I couldn't leave
the house without you know without
paparazzi without just hordes of people
anywhere I went in a grocery store or
you know wherever and I I think it made
life so difficult I I mean I I don't
think young people should be allowed to
be famous like there's somebody who
could come in and say no they can't this
is they're not mentally capable of
handling this I think that should happen
and because it just you know the thing
with former child stars having
breakdowns makes so much sense to me
because I think the world that your
throat thrust into kind of like puts you
right in line to have a breakdown you
know it's it's so abnormal to have
people follow
you around and what your want to capture
the moment with you but then at some
point it becomes normal to you even
though it's still a very abnormal thing
and I think when it becomes normal
especially to a kid and you were setting
that person up for failure as an adult
because then there's one of my favorite
lines from a book called freedom by
Jonathan Franzen I don't know if you
read it but one of the characters is a
musician and he's famous and he talks
about Fame being the thing that he never
want that he doesn't want but they'll
also doesn't want to live without and
it's like this weird sort of thing where
like you you don't want that but also at
the same time if he were to lose it he
would maybe lose a part of his identity
in a way your identity might get rapped
especially as a kid get rapped and gets
wrapped up into that Who I am as a
person is this this famous entity maybe
so I always saw it like I don't relate
to that I definitely just did not want
to be famous I didn't I didn't like the
experience and I couldn't wait till I
could just like you know put that aside
but yeah I wonder what he was finding
like what he was latching on to in the
fame I guess the identity thing makes
sense
I feel like particularly for actors
maybe there's there's a bit of an
identity crisis with being famous
because you're famous or something
that's not you like maybe it's easier
for Oprah or somebody who's like doing
something they're proud of and it's them
and you know or assume she's proud of
hope she's proud of what she's done but
I think if it's acting it's sort of like
you're known for this thing that's not
even you so you know who am i underneath
that and would I be famous if it were
just me my characters the famous thing
all the time and with us it's similar
it's never very rarely it's like hey
Josh hey Ryan it's hey minimal is dude
when I get a lot of time to like are you
one of the minimalize so I'm like yeah
they're like I don't know which one you
are
I know you're one of the minimalist you
know I think the the thing with the line
you're quoting from freedom is that we
all need some significance in life yeah
so Fame I think will certainly give you
that feeling of significance in people's
lives
so maybe that's what he's trying to hold
on to is that that significance so maybe
you know the answer to like that that
whole that sentence that you recording
there was you know find a way to be
significant in a meaningful way and
maybe that's maybe it's well the
significance thing is also what Lauren's
question is talking about here why do
people tear other people down because
they want to feel it's so common there's
a shot schadenfreude is the word like it
cuz it's such a common thing right I
think I think right I think one of the
reasons why people like to see people
fail is because they will see someone
like a child actor for example and how
good they are at their craft how happy
they are how they have the the rich and
you know famous lifestyle but then when
they fail they can say to themselves ah
yeah I knew it wasn't that good I knew
it look is like a piece of them want
that but then when they see someone fail
they're like oh maybe oh yeah I really
didn't want that because it's it's uh
it's not all that it's cracked up to be
you